[Applause]
we're back
as i uh as i mentioned earlier and if
you're just tuning in uh kumail nanjiani
not able uh yeah
tonight through apparently no fault of
his own kumail non-showy uppy
[Applause]
you're like a recovering stroke victim
that's a good job that's a that's a
trademarked
richter zinger yeah so uh our only guest
tonight
uh has been my assistant for almost 10
years
we've been through a lot together and
she always tells it like it is
please welcome ladies and gentlemen miss
sonam obsession
[Applause]
[Music]
now sona um
we didn't even explain i think jeff
frost our producer just said get into
makeup yes
and you didn't know why no one told me
anything but that's
kind of like how my job is just
regularly no one tells me anything no
one tells you anything and so i'm told
you do as you're told so we told you to
get into makeup and then uh you did
and then at what point did you realize
you were going to be the guest on the
show tonight and not kumail nanjiani
i think right when i was walking in like
you guys called my name and i was like
oh [ __ ] they really
ran out of stuff to do
have an applause just relax
you look fantastic
what are you doing my hair's all crunchy
what
no no okay that's better it's fine
it's cool let's tell people a little bit
about you you've been working with me
for almost a decade
uh for over a decade no okay no
that's how long i said working
[Laughter]
she goofs off a lot i do i do
do you have any weed
you're actually not kidding no we have a
lot of misadventures together you know
yeah how would you say it is working for
me and you can be honest
we have a fun chemistry
[Applause]
uh uh don't look at me
is it would you say fun would you say
dysfunctional dysfunctional but working
for you first of all i mean i've been
working for
for over 10 years so obviously i like it
uh but there are times when i want to
like poison your food
or where i want to i really think about
ways
to kill you slowly yeah
yeah i i'm kind of a crazy person i
think we can say that because you are
kind of crazy
hey hey hey what are you doing
characters for all of a sudden
what kind of character was that prepared
all kinds of bits okay yeah let's let's
take it easy on those
you are looking for a house right now
i thought that we could use television
to
get to a house because you and your
husband have been looking for quite a
while now
can i put you on the spot can you buy me
a house
can you buy me a house
buy me a house buy me a house
buy me a house by her house
buy her a house
well the answer is yes i can buy you a
house
you've been very generous to me over the
years
this is honestly true we just were sent
a clip
from camille and they think do they have
in the booth
can they put this up so here we go hey
conan sorry camel couldn't make it
tonight
it's my fault i don't know my lines
he doesn't know his lines
at least he said sorry
he said he was sorry yeah he seemed real
broke up about yeah
all right i love you sona you're a great
friend you're a great assistant son of
obsession everybody we'll be right back
you